and now that distance learning is a
reality the community is getting
creative with ways to make it work
8 news now reporter kate houston shows
us how a dance studio in the northwest
is offering some relief for families
soon this studio and dance connection
will be
filled with desks like this one as they
help families navigate distance learning
for nearly two decades dance connection
has focused on supporting
and instructing young dancers now the
studio is preparing for a new routine
with their enrichment program d.c
cares it's important to me to keep
some kind of normalcy for these kids
owner sherrilyn bienin came up with the
concept this week
students will bring their own devices to
attend virtual classes during the day
they'll have their own desk where they
can focus on school work
and take part in distant social
interactions bienin tells me this can
help parents balance their schedules
whether it's a working parent or just a
parent who
doesn't want to keep fighting with their
child to get their work done
in addition to school work bienan wants
to offer some comfort through stress
management techniques
like yoga and stretching on there to
help them with their stress levels and
their anxiety through the whole process
as well as artistic outlets such as
dance journaling acting and
singing not only am i here to help
facilitate and navigate through the
remote learning
but i also want them to be able to still
be able to express themselves
and to have that performing arts as
their outlet
dc cares is available for grades k
through 8.
the 30 spots will be split up into
different rooms based on grade level
keith houston 8 news now d.c cares is an
enrichment program not a licensed
daycare they will not be giving
instruction but rather helping kids with
a pre-assigned
curriculum